a Big Bang Theory star is stepping into
an iconic sitcom role and she has a big
robe to fill but what happened to the
original night court judge the brand new
Nightcore is a sequel series to the
classic sitcom that premiered back in
1984 and ran until 1992 with 193
episodes both Night Court series take
place in a courtroom setting in New York
City though what makes this premise
different is that night court as the
name implies covers the graveyard shift
this means that the stories and cases
are usually zadie Misadventures
featuring colorful characters of course
it takes somebody special to preside
over such a courtroom and the new Night
Court lets judge Abby Stone played by
Melissa Roush have a tremendous amount
of fun despite the lofty and often
humorless role fans of the original
Nightcore will remember the judge who
held sway in that courtroom Harry
Anderson's judge Harry Stone Harry wound
up residing over the original night
court because the mayor was simply too
busy and overwhelmed Doling out
positions within the government and
Harry happened to be one of the few
people to answer his phone Harry soon
found himself working the night shift
courtroom in Manhattan though on account
of his young age and unique Outlook on
life his rulings were usually much more
personable and understanding than what
many may experience when coming face to
face with a judge the new night court
with judge Abby Stone presiding has
already established that Abby is Harry's
daughter and in one of her first
interactions with series veteran Dan
Fielding played by John Larroquette the
two discuss Harry Dan was the prosecutor
in the original Night Court meaning that
he's exceptionally familiar with Harry
as the two had something of a friendly
antagonism however Dan mentions that
although Harry and himself hadn't been
close in quite some time he offers
condolences on Harry's passing which is
kept vague I was sorry to hear about
your father
and we lost touch over the years but he
was
a great guy actor Harry Anderson was
beloved on the original Nightcore and
other famous shows like cheers and his
death in 2018 at the age of 65 due to a
stroke was a real loss for the
television landscape the new Night Court
Revival decided that instead of
recasting the role they instead would
reflect real life with an off-screen
death this has not been lost on those
who remember the original show with
quite a few expressing their thoughts on
social media on Reddit fans tried to
play some of the seemingly random items
delivered to judge Abby Stone's office
with one viewer pointing out the
armadillo was always in Harry's office
so that made me smile the pool ball was
later explained in one episode Harry
gets depressed and quits he becomes a
pool Hustler Dan basically calls him out
for quitting and gives him a speech that
brings him back the ball is a Memento
Harry cap to remember this another fan
on Reddit brought up the rapid fire
nature of the jokes on this new
Nightcore and felt like if the show
slowed down the laughs would be a bit
more robust your past your feelings
you've put your whole life in a box and
won't let anyone in I went hold on a
second am I in the Box am I putting
things in the Box I kind of lost the
thread the fan then mentioned that the
late Harry Anderson had great comedic
timing and added the guy was a stand-up
comic and a street performer first and
that way of delivery comes through in
his lines Melissa is a sitcom actor
going through the paces here she needs
to relax into it still it seems as if
many still fondly remember judge Harry
and are happy to see him referenced in
the new show
[Music]